MMONCAE OCSIEN A C
ASE'CIA'RES ARADRY FO
ANERSSO
NGYTHI.
>>CA COMRTUPST SPO ASPS C-AN
PUCEERIC SVIITNG ALO W
E
LER OTHETEROONVISI P
RSVI.
OUVINGGI YNT A RT OWTO
CC
>> NAIT,NIANFE PROORSSS
EX
EINAME THNG O TENOISI
BEIAN EERUSSND A U
AIKR.
THE ORO PGRAMPRNEN W APOCHOAES T
ARRESECH AT ASORGEGE W
NGN
UNIV HOSSIERTYS
TTSHI
SATINVCOER
.ON
IT HOUS  IANANR DA.
H
>> AOT O LF ACANRICE VOI
S,
SSNCE VOIWE WS,HAT
AD
DTOO
Y
OF
ING LEVOMESIC FRONE UKRA''S
OW
N EXPRE OTSER ALITIY NLPO
N
UKRATE INBURUSSLS AO D
N IN
IANRAUKINATIO RELNDNS BRO
C
TSEPHAT  TETH RH ESEAIS
TH.
EAE THSPAY TKERSODL  WILBEM FROU
ESTIC NIONAATLVE UNIITY,RS
AN
OMHER OTFRAYLO BRNI U
,
FROTHEANR OMHE TNA NATIO
L
IVLATY OSIF WCA AMYDE,
AN
OMHEOTR FR T M
HAECNIC
VEITINIATISCA ADEMY -
-
DE IATNITIIVATES ACA
.
I LLWI NATE OTTH TGRAM PHERO
N
HERERESOD  BYAR PONARAS EUSI
A
O
ES
>>IGH HCIPP AREATE --
I
APPRVETEIA IT
MRYUCH.
FORKS WEE ANDONS ETS, L U
Y
TOHE DECIPREN, EVTHHOUG TH
EN
ISY.CLARO IT
TEAF WR EE OFKS GT
ETENSINIVLY ANAARS,SI WE NOTE QU
EITUR SS WHE AT I.INGOG ON
ITS  IASI CRIS,EC NOT N
Y
UKRAINCRISBUIS, TLO A G
BL
.
ISCRIS
THRONTLF OEL B AARUSND
,
INCEFAS SI C THERIS.YNYD S ANMA
NGPLAIEXNISSHAT  WRU ISIA. DOING
R
G FOINR
.VASIINON
ITRTS IM IPOTAN TTOO
NDDERSUNTA OFKINDR  OIO INVAS
,
WHERN ND A WHEDANT WHA
CICEUMRCSTAN
S.
IS T T ARE WAYT PRO EVEN
OM
FRNGAP HPENI
?
REIS THE V AERY COS
LYICEMAL OED
ANRGIZ
DATITIINMION G
WE WHATEEN VEHA S WEE TINHE
ANON MTHS FER UALLSND
HF
ETHOSOSNA SCERI.
T ANWE CNOLLE QUITTE.
S IT IGTHSOMEINT THA A THEUT
TI
NOWHIS
WHY HE TYHI THAT NKTH
NEEDECO  TBE DHTEDID RIG A
STARTINGM FROHI SOMETIS TNGHAT
ONGOING N  ITHEIN.RE KML
RATEMODEGBES IN SILTEN -
-DELI
SI
TINPUS PANT COUERNDRT A
A
FTSOYR OVE.KRAI UNE
PTHATT VES S
THINGS ILUDINCNGTI STAHES ONOF T
D AIR ANA PUT IG PUS TTINDEUNR
O
EUSEST  AINS VIDIDUAL
IN
UKRA
E.
FINATHE ONREL ASS I
HE WREA
ONINSHGT WASSENT PREJORG INMA
ONREGI WHIS BENDN PUHAT TIIS
G.DOIN
ITNK THI IGGS  IBIHAER TNT
.
ASIT HNGET SOMHI DOIT WH
R'E'S NATO OPATERCHNS WIOHI
D
ROTHAT TSSLEY T
TUT  SAYLY ID.TOU LOU
WEEARE A ALRDY SGIINEEG REERSTED
SMEMBERIV GGIN UED
DECT
S OFMADENDPORA COR
ONTI.
THAT WOUA DE BLDE  MEMAC FTO
H
TOU MHIP BEEMRS
IIFT
S.INCONTUE
RHPERE TAPS,HETHSO ISE
INGPP
HAERG ENINOVLA THECK. SEA
S AWEREGEEINTL BATERPSESHI HE
THWI AD CAN RIANGSTO FNALA
NG R
NE
MESOREINTHG HES A WELL,
PN
Y ANGEURNCO NOWED  D YETKNT OWIN
.
AT WWHERE S AIS VINEEG
ALAR
NGMI ANDHA WTTERES  IIN
G
S US IHETHATRERE ABE NUMRF
ESLAPS.
TIPUN K WASNOWN AS A
LAY,
WHMEONSOE ISO  A SDEWD HRAN CDOL
AYPL
.
ENWHSOE GO HT ATAS PSIONE AND
CA
BEEO AMEN IDGULOE.
REAL HISE ING TLYRYO T POS
SO?
TILUON
ESE S MOVEAR TGNDESIEDO
INPAAICERTN RTS
LACS --E' BTOK A. RUSSI
WE T
BLL W
OBABPRLYN SEE O OURAI UKRNI
DESI, AEAT TEX OF ICPLIT
IN
SIVAON.
WETI SLLO SU ALSHROUERFF T AGH
T
LO SSSTF RE UNDERY -- MAN
SWHO'NG BEI M
WEVIE HANGUN HSDREDF O CALLS
E THAND ERHAVEN BEE SAJ MORRIGNT
OMCKS TAFR THEIN MTRY ISOF
ENCIAGES A MANNDYTHER OHING TS.
T O M
Y, BANUT SOME.
TH CRLAIINESGHAUTE  SOMOF
EITHR OVEEHTIG HER-- IN
TS
OUEID
AINE U.
IT
N A B'SEE KINNTENOFD  ISE
ATIOSITUHEN RE ALS BUT
E,EV T
S SOREHE IME KIND OELI
FN
DICTNE ISTEN RM O
F W HOWE
ET I AHEND TNSRI AMECA DUE.
TH
AE WAERS  SURITECY CNCILOU
ME
INGET ANDWAUSSI RA
S
PRTEDEN. THERE
AN
DIN SAYGNSME ARICA
INVEATIGING THELE WHOPL HOOA.
L
AC SLYAW LOT ATH OE
SITU
BEFIOATNSE.OR
IN
G ONUDCLINE LYEASAR.
R OTONHT
IT
.
THWAS ET MO AUNOF RUSSSIAN N
O
TOURDEORRS.
SOETHMY ECONOTHEY,  SAY
IE RUNTO
ANIC P B ANDAUSEECWE
E'R SINGEE MORAJAP CALIT
FLIGSM  FROREEVKI IN NTCE
WES A BUTO,LS
A IT'S IT STIUAOH
EER OION OSPPIT BEOUSHLD
ONE
SID
ANEE ERTHACK  A LST TOFRU
OCKBA T 2019
-HI WCH W- HEAS
E
ANDE HAC F BED AMALACKILND
T
HERI WOREDUT ABOT MI HE GHBE
G P.
,AN VOLEVY SKBELIBS
ITLF.IM HSE
T I DON'ESE ANYNCE VI EDEOFHA TT
H
BU'SAT A W
EID SPRTIOND EANO
HERE IN UKR
NEAI.
ULI WOD SE  LIKTOEE TT ONUR O
I
DE,S  IT'TRTIMPOANT  THAWE
VEHE T
-  -IN P.LACEAN
ED WEG, TRYINOIE'RE W DNG
RT. BEL
--
BEST  .
IN
ACOME  SPL THEESRERE AORE M
OWRVESNE NSIND T AEN THAONN
OT.RS
ENT BURUSHGSIN MEHTIG TAK HIS
SIE
.
BU
SIGNTHT E CE OICIFANIARUF SS
ISOF TONO E BABL PHERO
RECTORNSIO FS ULL A AND IT'SDI
SONTOR IMPTA-ED -MP INTORTA
BE
EE CAUSONAY D SHA WE VENEOMEO
IN CHEE OFRG TOUNC CIL
G
ENAND THT HE N TEXYTA THEYO, S
NO,E WE AR NOT.
OTH
'SAT NOTD GOO
.
ETHERNO IS TUC MEIRKH WO BNGDO
MAE
MEN  ISO PSLACEV K BUTIE
SE
YANONPARARETITFOR S LENE ALO
AT
D, INAL FLYD LII'KEOFO
ANON OPINI ON TCT SHEUBJEHA TTSO
E  PMEEOPLYSA TTHA
G PUTINOT
F HIMSELUP HSOIGH  A TREET THA
LDHE COUBT N'CLIMW.OW DN NO
I N'DOTIEVE BEL SO.
RFOHE INTONALNAERTIF ALL A O
SU
ENDDGHT E  HMIT HIESPREN
F
AS A LOFDEEAR  WNT COURYHICH
GR
NTATABS TEION FMOANOR MY NTHS
O
IT
'S SAJ A MOROFHOW  F.ORCE
A
SA MES IHIGE WCHSKI WORNG.
TH
EYLLEAT NEEDY  ILDULD WOCO
DO
I CT.
TH
EY NISDEEED THIN KD
LICAGHLIT BEEUS5  40, 4ARYES
SINCCOLDTH W.AR
IFTEESE CALA B HS,E'LLE A
.
HERO
HINK ISO THA TTIN PUTOST M
DEFDEI
HYELAD,E'LLD  FA -TA CERIN-
ATNE CAHO
SE'ATW TH HS
EVAC
HIEDT  SORHI TSRO FNT.
UGTO
OANDFF. O
XTOURODEL CIA OF S
NIYLORBA U
RSITVEY.
>> TNKOU. Y
HENRK, THAN F YOUIZ OORRGANGIN
ETH P IELAN AND'M GLA BTOE
PA
ORTF
AN'VWEEEA HRDM MU FROIPLTLE
RSEASPKE A THEEALRDYSSIOIS DCU
THE
NTUR CRE- INUS R
H N
DUT PIN'SLS GOA
NSELAT RIO
W
OB
OUSLVIY I PS E ONTHLY OR
TH
VIKEY E DION?SI
MA
R INKE R ISIA USSOST'
EN
FTOOCUSM  ON HITHWI Y
TS
LLTES O OY NLPARTFTO SRY.
INRKY  MREMA TI S WANTS ONFOO CU
HER E THOTF THRTPA OE SND
A
ATTHS  IONAINE UKR
TH TENSINISG NSION TH OE
UKRAIARUSSN-N INBORDERF O
SY
C MAMPTOTIOF AAK BRE ODOWNF
DIICOMAT ET FFORTOES R TOLVEHEL
Z
.IM
Y
WHISHA TT CL?RI
RST,FIORA, RUSSI THEIN MSK
TSREAGEMENEDDD ARESS
RO R
CUSERITYRN CONCEATASS SOCI
ED
WITH YOU'SNEUSH P FORAT NO
ERSHMEMB
ERD O HEARVE TV
HE LASSWET EK
OMFRHI RUSNGENIP DBOTSLOMA AUT
ABERCONCN THOUT E PTYBIOSSILI OF
R
ERRA COOPEHON WTIITHE T T
E
WEST.
D W WOHOULETH MINSKME AGREE
SOES? THI
F PARTHE A OWENISTH
MYE SF  OPARTF
IM ZBAS.TH
G WATOULDE IVITGE S ATRON
RMO
SARVEAINE UKRICY P'SOL A
NW
THLDOU REQREUI U TOAIKRNE
NEUTOPADT LIRATYSKEDR  ORIEDRM
O
ITCTNFLI WITHIN S B
RSO.
ONRETHE AS FORAN D THEEM AD OF
UTLTU STATHS WIINKR U,AINE
ER 4OV0%CTD Y WOLLULPPORSUT
UTLI FORNE UKRAI
AND
NGBR
THE R TES OFIM ZBAS INWO
D ULMAKE TSHIVE OG.HERWLMIN
G AS LONW  MASOSCOWSANY
POSS -ITILY OF-INSK M
.
IT WASILLI WNG TTYET
E'S RAUKINEMBETONA MHIRSP.
OVT TW LHEASOEARS Y,HE TSEER TTW
O PDAIROCLME RLIEPUBCS
R
AHALFNTWHPL PEOE O
IV E
ULERE THWO RRELID EFF --OO
CEAN RUSEDSIIZ CITSHIPEN
WH
HICIV GES MCOW OSA
ORMAL
TOETEXPRT Y OPENLTHEFEN DD
E
ONCA IN  TSEHERE IAS
RYMILITAIC CONFLWIT TH Y
AN
CRE.
WE AONFL CTHICAT T
TO
FOR ONEN  THEAS LGHEIT
AR
S.
WEEE SNGIL KLIS AOMND SE
THE T RULESOOOOIAF
THRO THEAW TS.OP
LF OHI TSCREAS TEAV FOR
ONCAESLATIPOT  AANY
ITEOU WLD BEDRI TGGERY  BTHE
TE
INIFNSIED
E IO VLENCINOM Z
D
ANEDUS JTIFIY BHE TD TO NEE
UENTFREQ SISSIUSANSO THE.RE
O
DW  UKRNEAI'STU POSREEHA CNG
DE CEEZELLNS?AN I
--
EL ZENSK
IN
IOTERNINATENL AUNADIS, TCEHE
IEDN
GN FOREIARS DEERCL
EI CT MITMOMEN THETO
LMFULFILT ENOFHE T MSK
RE
AGENEMT.
FO
OWLLINGHE TS'DV AISOREE MTING
LASTEEK. W
THENEBS AGRIN MSK AREMEEENTHE T
I
SF TH OE W
K OROFHE T FOR
T
E TI SHEAMME UKRNIAIAN
SCIOFFIALEDMI DISSS M THE
AGEMENUN AS ABWORKLEND A
DANE
OUNGERS.
,LIFAMIAR ADYLREAHIS T I WEEK,
T
OF THE MEESK AINGRWOMEULILLULDE
AN
ES THE D OUCTRTIONTHF E
Y.COUNTR
THES
EXUL MELY
USCLIVE
TSATSTEMENEN SCLEAT R MSAESGE
COTO MOSKRTHW AT ULONEAI NO ERNG
TAKES TNDRATIEM DOCCRACK
OFINGTO SPP THEICTON CFL
RISLY.
AS
VE WE'EE SN, TOSHE MT
LIMPCOELS
AN
STOINTDP O CANY BENLIT MIL
R
IN
ATUR NE.
,CONDSELYY'ELEN ZSKS HOS PTUREAS
EBECOMEN VELESSBL FLEXIE
AD
REMO H
DLARINE.
EXAMFOPLE,ISE  HDISMSSE
THE
ITSSPOIBILY OFIREC DTITHKSAL W
RATISEPAST LEARSDE.
LENS
ZEMISS DKYIS TESHE
SSIBITILYF ON  ASTAMNEY,HI W
S
T
WANL OY Y TOOL RVE
SE
TYCURI.
HE
ES JON
.
AEJ RECTSBI PNYOSSITYLI OF
GETTGIM Z
SO TFROMMPRAS  PAKERESAL M
ARDLTO HERINBEAN
NL OY
RSUNTOODN I DOM THETIESC
POLI
CATIL CONXTTE.
NCSIE WNINGIC OFFE,E  H
BEER UNDRE PESSUR OEF THHTIGHASN
N
WRIOSPG SUICUS OFIS H
MO
MENTVES.
T PRETEXRFONOERUT REVOLEAS A
OR FOR HIS A.PRAPOVAL
ERHE UNDANSTDS THAT ANUTIED
F
EASOCTLI SN MUCH MEDEO
ANG
VA HIM FESOR.
TO CRI THECATILYNN  LGY ORASTTEF
INRAISGS SI TENONONRORHE BDE
D
ANO  TRTE RAISFUHER C AOSTSND
AA
TTOPT TE CHANGEL
ZSKY'ENS
LICLCAARION.AT
EVHE TEA THRT
OFIO INVASN HAS
.
JUST SENEV MAGO,THONS  CIT
E
RECERN CONEDH  WITONUPCORRTI,
N
IOFLATN,
ING URITYTILI PCES.
BUTOW, N DS ISBAAN BACK D THE
R
ISISIT WH
IT.FO
STTHR E WENERKR UAINET
I
ESENREPRN  ATS SIGOFEAKN W
BEA
US ONLY WTTLEK EALIOULD
C
MAKESIAN RUSEPLO DYS P
B.
ONLY/3 THOUGHAT
SKEL ZENY
ANIECHF DHE TSITIZ CEN PFERREV T
B
Y4U 3.
ZE
NSLEKY A HNDIS OAREENONT
NOWD IN TIEONPI ONI P.OLLS
REIGNOEG THT HR TEANOWOULT
MA
T KE IGO A
THTOEDE NES
AN BN OPE
RE
N GNITCOIOOFHE TUNDANTALME
DRNDS BEERHI
THE T
SIO.
REETHAIN MWA TAKEA --YSST FIR,TH
THE REAT OFUS RSIANIO INVASN.
SECOLYTH, E ON W TAYHETE WESRN
E
ERADSAN C -YIS-  BNFLU ICIENNG
H
E DIPOE MOT L LTIATCREOS PTU
ONSKGR ANTEEMES A
IRT
S,DOWNEDT  THANEFO BS TOE ULED
ITEPSNTH T
KMINO
YOANK U.
THA>>NK Y.OU
>> NEXURTER SPEAK
S FRM
UTIONNAALYVERSNIIT OACEMBDEER
EMW LAACADY.
>> VNKHA YOU.Y ERMUCH
D I WOULESOAL LIKINO  TCONTUE OL
IDPRSO, ESENT ZSKELENY
HAD
PPENHA.ACHAT W WARILL NOT
TORDINCOG IM H,
NI UKRAIAN
MEGOT
IL $12 B
DUNGNTHI TS MOH OF AIONREGGSS.
READT BUALYBRUAN  IFERY AND
MARC
H.
STE INMUAY P A $BOUT3
LL
MIION.
TH
STE LOEA YR TO YOVEAR ER
IARAUT
SSIARU,AIANNI LOST 2 ABOUT0%
NI UKRAISANND ATAV HE NO YET
ACREHED ANOS PITIO OF 23.
GEY,LLT IS WHAHE T M
ISOUERS  THAT UKREEMSNEAI SDANG
TO BF--E  OER-E NEVWARINNDG
TH
A.SI RUS
THEKR UOVANAINI GTOENERNMT ELD A
PO VE TBETHREREPAD AT
HE T
S LICONFCTORWARI HYBD YR MA
E
AT ESCANALION.
OP CFLICONTTA WILL KES  LES
ATEHEE  TIMETHAI UKRANNI
EC
IOMY ONISN - A-YC C.LE
Y,R FOTODA TOU RESESRC,Y MOSTL
I
AGUREC
ALCTS.RO PDU
AND,NASIA  RUSANHE
T
ANROEUPE UNI AONRE THEOR M
IAR.
D ISR YEA
NA CHI ISHE T
E TH BEHIST
NRAINUKIAAR PMIER, TN0 IONLL
ANLLARDOS DKR UAINELS ASDEO PEND
ON- THE -UK FROM INRAIAN
LABON A--ND I
R YEA,GA AIN
T
ICORAL RISORECD  A $BO15
LL
BIION.
SO
THEOU NTRYIESE  HAVTORDX  EFO
D
AE RE INCASTAMILIRY
ENNG M BUT AEORMP I-TANTOR -
S
-- MORE  IN
RAINUKE.
ATWHD  KINOF,ARAI UKR
NE
AGAIT RD SIUSA ANEME THSTATTEN
OFANKR UAINIIEIN MORITS AHE T
R
COTIECONF O REFEFENM,OR DVESI
RM.REFO
THEYEY CT ORTHNGHAELMOS A
TV
ERY DAYND AHE TY CICTRT
CHEATH O
SO TTEHE SMENTMOS ALENRE GER
A
S
INR
GE.ID
ETHAR MILITYY TRAT SEGISHAT TUK
INERAIN IS GOTOG  REACH
LI
MIWIRYTA -- THUS RA.SI
UKEINPT ADOED DOC THEINTRE OF
RYTA NATNAIOLSSIS ANCTAE.
BUI
T
AY TOD T AHERERE ABE NUMR
-OFS
IARAO UKINNAB IS OUT
TR0,00260 PSOOIOND N AATLNA
AR0  52,00DANHE T-RO TS,OP
DAN -UR DABLE-TI POTENAL
ADONTIAL
30 1,000OL POEMICEN T
TRAINO  TDO SEOM M INY AR--
,
TOODAY TVEE  WHABOUT A A
HA
LION MLFIL FROM 13000,0
RYLIMIL
ARYN
SPD COULDNC IVEESREAS ERY Y
M
FR 1ONIL.6 BLI IN3  201TO
OU
ABT B 5NLIONIL I 22.02
HSWESR,R
COV
SALAOC AESND SLIAUARANTS,EE
A
0%NDY  ONL%30
ITOR F MILYAREQ
PMUIENT.
ISONEAC FT, WAV HE ARMYGEAR A
WHORE AOT V NYER GOOPAD IDBE
USCAE --UN HSDRED. .SARDOLLS
HMOPER NT TOFO00 $1,0 RSDI SOLER
N
INTERNASAI UKR ANDNET' INOTS
E
RY SG,PRISURINHERE T ARENGOU
J
RA
UKIAINNY. ARM
NRAUKINIARM AYRENJ EOYS
GH
HIEV LELPU OF BLRUST T
H
EOPUL PN.AT
A
AYSEW F D TO WARD FGOORND A THE
RE OONFNEKR UANIAIE SOC
PRTIDENEL ZSY ENSKHA
DIG SNE AS
CREMCH WHI DANDSEAO IN TCR
E
E ZETH OF E
ANKRAI UNIRMY ABY
1,00000 T AOPS RO--ND30 1
O
TR WILPSL-- BE NGCC AORDIO T
RTHE WA O--N
ISCE[INDLERN] AOT O LPSTRF OO
M
OW H BUTHEYLR AEADY
FI
UCE NANCEDNATIO ALTND HH
REC.
ONOR REFMPO URED BRTY
LE TO KYBEME IMPLEED INTN
E
TH
UT FURE, WAVWIE LL HE
F OOTRPS OETHNI UKRAIANY.RM
AI
AGER NN,OT VYEL WNDPAL ID A
RY WT NOVELEL T.INRAED
ASAND TER IN MISENSE DOFEF,
S
EADY R TO --
IL0B 2 MLION
ANDRA TGININ FOR TTOHEM E
T
MEETO SI RUS
AN
MYTHEN OR BR.DE
IT
'S
UL MINDFF  OTHEEC SOND WORLD
WAR.SO
OUHA WT SHLDE DO B?NE
TH
ENIANKR UAIIL MY ARIS A
TND A
POL IA--INDI [BLE]ERSCNI
SULDE TAKNT ITCOO ACUN
E THO
AR W.
I RIS SUSETHEYD TE WRO
AR
BOCLESTI A THEUT
A RUSSI
S HYREA
EPNDG SEINCOORLD W S WARLETY
N
OFROOPS.
SO THEUS RSIANAR MILITYOCTRIN
E
IS A HINTRE OFTEI-CH WAR IN
C
ATEPRH IVILIT MYARORCE FS,
NE
SIRATI OPEOK, ONTOPL S
AN
AI UKRNE SCID HOULDEDE FORITD
SEUL S ANDHOD DO T
HE
ONOMECIC,  STUFFW THHOEYULDHO
I
ENSESP F THIORS.
DAT KWHIN OF THIRETHS AT A
NDNEED ALD WOW H
ON
ECISOMTSID DECE --
[ILECEISRNIB] AOND SNDEC
AO
IMPOER VY ISANRTT  THE
ECO A
DIMEY'OMS AS FIONSN ARS
PMENVEDELOANT DOC DRACY.
FO
RUSMAR NYANSIPEAKERS - AND-
K
ERAIN IS A CCAE HOICBEUSES IT'
AMI COMENTTM-- TO [I
IBISCENDRN] BULET
IF UAINEKR
TE
IOSTINITUTOR ANSND CION RUAND
VEPORTYND AFI POOR NCNAIAL
MAMEGENT AMA -ND- HURIN GHTS
PR
ON, ECOTTILLE THFUITY AJ MOROF
E
PEOR FUSSI RAN -- T NOA
ON TORTUP SPOSI RUSA IN
UK
RA
BUOUIF YINLE HAVE E  PFTEOPLOWH
KEULD WOLIO PROTT THE
CTNTATE S.
>> VNKHA YOUYER
MH,UC.ETYA TNA
R
HANR  IS OUXTNE
SP
KEEAR.
, WVEXI? ALE
>>
TSE U I MELF.YS
SO
IRE PREPAD ANT PAT
IOSE
BAD ON THEL  FULOFEMOCRACTI
T
INTIIAVE.
A FNNDOUATIOHI WCHOU WLDRT SUPPT
ETHER ARE NOW -TIC BAS
AY
THFI CONRM OUR
N MAI RT.ESUL
ANDLL ACTUAY HPYAP TIZSUO MMAR
E
WHY ISENS  IHAPPGINO  SI
HAO TLLUS IE TRABOUT
THEPPY
INIAUKRAN VNTWPIEOI.
MIN F WOPD PELEITH
DI
ENFFERTWS VIE.
ERSI RUSAS  IINWANTGO T
RON OF
ATO N TOEJ R
LITAMIRYP UILD B UTHWI YOUCR
E.AN
DOESWAT NTS TO
AUL FFILLND
SOTS
ALPR TO IDOVE SCIPEAL
RFO TIED CC OUPORIERRTEITS AND
L
MNES ATY T
TANTMIO LIS.
BY
HE T W,AYAI UKRLL- NE -WE,O S
E
UST METRAEMON DSTTEWE AWAY
HA.
, SOHI TIS TS HE
EINE  L--
.K
E UEIN LPOIS SE UPRT
TO NOAT
S THIS I J--UST A MT.EN
,AH.OR SRY
TH ISEMOC DTURNTIRAC  IN00 20
N
DHE TUN YO SUPHEEE T SSPORT
BABELLSICAY E CAUSOFSI RUSA
ACON.
SOSSHEN IA ISAY SING,K, O
NE UKRAILOS NO ANBCS E
AT
ST
WEN-AVE  HNOOCBL STA A THANDT
S  UFROM AN.REGGSSIO
ENAND THOU Y SEE DPS U ANDNSOW
IN SRTPO OFO  NATTBU
UG NOT HE,
.TUACALLY
SUPPTHE TORS IICAL BASLYTABL S
P
ANS
AND MAYOW DNSE B
AINEEXPLDS RIPEODONENOF TSI
S
HERE INCASEN IWE ST
ORE
N
O S BICLYASH
A  RUSENSIG, SAYISIN NAT
PAN'DOT EX TNDO U
AIKRNE.
'SITDAERNGOUS
RA
UKIAINNS.
THE REHIS DRUM ISEA
BNGTI,
TH
ISMOE RE SUPPO NAT FRTORINO
E.RAUKIN
REGNOW,DIARNGSKENY HIS AND
COITONARIS WH
BOR
VE -Y
ANNKSCHEA DNG TTHERHIS.
RSOFLL A'S, HE A P.SIVIASST
C
ESPROMOMISITH W
TI.
HE
ELIE BFN  IDOTTINSIG  ANDWN
TA
SINLKG TOVEOL THE IUESS.
I'M R TDYO I SOLVEANT D
ZE
NSLEKY
E VE MADRY S STEIOERUSPS
TOSN,UT PZELUDI INCNG -- THE
L
FOAHDRA WIT TROL WAOFDS OPAN
T
HERHI T
WA
AHE TRE-F CEAIRE?
NO
.
ORONFULT CN --TI CON
TNUO
LSHELNE UKRAI.
T LYNI UKRAIANDI SOL
T
TENOFKR UNIANAI C.ILIAIVNS
NO IT'S  IIN TT HEERESNTTS
M
TR
STTIL A MFEARITY DE
NSIS
TH B WOULDE
RA CZY.
NSRAUKINIAON D'T ST.POUPRT I
IAUKRAINNS BVEIEN  ISEMPCOROMI
T FOT BUNOILADE RCPH WE'PHELIARE
GLKTAIN AMBO AUTTYTI,
AREIAINNSEADYOT N R TO VEGIA
STY AMNE LEA TTOHERSDETHE OF
SES TIPARASTBUTAS BLYICALO T
HEATCOMB TNDNKM RA AE. FIL
IS, YEAHTH ISBL POSE.
EIUKRAINM
OSHOOPLEPE W AREDDNVOL IVE
D
S SCALLO-EDTETA
TU STRUC
RT
SOLEDALS EO PPLE'S PUREBLIC
THE LEDDND AER LOW LEFT.
ONO-BO AUT SINLLCAED MTRISIES
IDD ANPRES OTSEN ANDERTH
S
TOFHELLCAEDEOPL PSE'
REPU
ICBL.SO
CALLBA, SIYEL ZYSK,RI TED
N PUTID INCONTUEHISACPP AROH.
IIS O
UT,HE TBE NUMR
WT,
BEEVE THATWISI RUSA
YOU SRE INCRMEEDSAS AS
KYZE.
BOIT'S AUT0% 6 OFSE THW
BEEEV
EHAT  TTHKR UNIAIAN
N.RAUKINIANTAR -ND- STDTE W IARN
WEEEAV HE FRMSDO, WE AAV HE TV
D
BY WAY T,  HWEAVE THE PRE
F
THE PNITOSIOOR F RUSN
EO
TV IF ONTIISTH CEDNU.
SOOW N, N THEEXTLI S-DE -,GA AIN
'SESRO PGRSION OFUS RSIA
SISTASED BMILOCAY L ORTANTLIS
SL
AR. WBA
A SIREWHLINED , HIC
JPPENHAEDNET INUS O Y
EAST
JUN  IONE YEA
BAGAIN,FAUSEEI
NGNI.
W, TSHI IS
UT A --CTOB O
ERS
COONSIS FROM U
KRAI.NE
HOW
Y MANAI UKRPPS NIANSUORTT
MELEBUT T HO SUW YO OHA PERPSNE
T MAINS.SS IUE
ISTHS IONNSLARATIF OAW L.
TBU THENSEG RIONEWH, ICH
OFMUALCI FORTILAONNS IN MIKFIAG
T.EMREEN
W,NO Y HOW SOUEEAN MY YOU
COIAINNS THA ANYTHIS T HOWPLA
OU RNEETURDO
T KRTHNE IAIN E
T
STWA THAUST BEFOS RE01 2
4.
ISSH
S OT L NESANTH 5.4%
HOWPE MANY LEOPIE BELD SVEHOUL
ROT GE-- FM U?
AIKRNE
LLYSIBACA FIG THEE URISE.
L
OT'SIT N INBO AUTES Y, IN
ISIOPROVNINSK MMENTGR AEEISS
LAPONOT PUR AT A
CAWEHAAY S TTKR UAINE.N
DESUNCESK MINNTEE AGRMES?
NO
CAEWE IF EAD RSK MIN
RE
AGENTSEM,
DI ANGO  T
--
MBNUER ONEFICES ASE-.RE
TNUMBERWO ISIT WRAHDWAL,
OCHEXANGEFNE PRISOO ARSND S
ANSOOR FTH ANDNLY O
N, THE
TICAPOLIES.ISL SU
SOICAL BASLYOTCAE NNOV ME
WAS P IICOLITALS,SSUECH WHI
R
ELL REAY00 2UTIT5, WHO
IMTEMENSEING RORITYCU PONVISIS
U
T
NHERE T'SFICEASO E-RE
SIRAINUKE ENC 24.01
IAGAIN,SYT'E
H ER
THE
LLS A  IWI OFUT PIN.
SA SWISNA NATIOFRL OM O. .CWAS
SA, IF YES YOU SEE
FLAS
S HE--HEN  WIS ITITS AS
HEIG
AHTND Z--ERO MI OF
NSKRE
AGT.EMEN
ICWHHITNS MEA, ER'S V
PLE-CEENT AS.FIRE
IF
RE THE ISOL A PILALITIC WL,
TH
EER IE-A CES ASRE.FI
AN
N,D  FOR
NI UKRAI
S,E
EAR ARA DEMOC
CY P
WEFERREHI TS.
L USE PAALOF OUR, IC VTIMS
E
AR ONIO DIVISNO S
MO IT'S
BENEALCI FOR UISTOS  LEW
,PEOPLENYOR F AAINI UKRAN
VERN
GOWHILNTME, FOE RUTIN P
-
NOT
TE OLEVIOW MONSI HYAN
NAMTE IBA DS ON
-AN URB -RU
NSSIAISEL TEVION.
DANAL FINME, LELYT RESE PNT U
.
ERIS-  A -ONOM SNRUSSE IA
.NERAGELS
LLWE STIAV HESIUSANEN GALERS
FR
OM IKR UAINENUS RA.SI
EED RIN LE, A ITINGASTND A THE
ETHREIF DFENCE IOUS ABT S
BY TAY, WAI UKRIANSNE
GL STRONY
VOTAIREC DT SLKITH  W--
E
ANTHF 50% ONSAIKRNEIA
AGTNST  DIRECTHLKTAS WIUT PAI
T
BU TTO THEALK NUT PIN I T
HE
PRCE OF ITIONERNTNA -AL-
GARD
REINEG NSTIOTIAONH  W
ITTHE
ER OFIT MIL.ANTS
TH
IS WAS H NOTTINVIS IEN.ON
AGREN, TAIHE A NOTREEN INDEP
ETHEY'R I NOTNTEPENNDDE
CS
ALLAT.
ITNOT E NVEIKE IN
YOHE T -- N
,ORO -- THW BY RSIUSA
CR
INIMALS M ANDITILANT.
Y, TNAFILLHETERN WESIONEA RCT IS
TED.BELA
WEM WH F--ROAT W
NOWHEE AR,
ATWHS  I THE BDONEUTNL OY
ICG THINWHYH MA SN PUTOP TIIS
E F THRENG OTHENIKR UAIAN
ARWE SO AV HD LAE DEYETHE
SUMY
PPORT PPSUARLY OMSO T
RAINUKE ATI ESSNDENONS ANALD LY
R W AFNOTEYEEIARS OF T
HE
WAPO
PENTTEIAL ONRSAL SCTANIONS
T AGAINSDTIPUN ANIS WHAT
ANIMPORTTSORS  IAUATTH BEC
E
TH ISSIBA S POOFITILY  T
-CL
SOMITED LELIDITAR MILY
OPERTE
IT'IOATN,VES RY IMP
HO SETHCAME ARINATS TH
U
INNRSIOF OSIUSSROAN TOP
BEULN
SIGRAGS
BYHETHAY W, EREEES  ISWPING
TINEXIANZAEE -- ONCRNGPI
ZAANNEXI
I'
MMYORRY S,  INGLI ESHNOTS
D
GO.
OM AM FRER OLDAT GENERN.IO
ANONXI EZATIF OHE T- -EA S
SH
RURIE A WNDE D'TON SEE
ANY
NSIOEXPAN ENTI ESS
EY,LL W A L SEEOTPEOP OF LEA
H
USCAO LLO UN TNDRSDETA
PUTI
N' CS.
CEONRN
WEA AV HE LOTEROM T LEF
LE
ANED IEFN TOT ANDM  FRO
TT
LECE FORSURN  IYO.
FOTME I A WASAYSLWUR A SISEPR
E
USECA OYGINARILLN I MIYOUTY H
W
RET
HEIC BASSF  OATWH I
DO.
ILIBIT
RITYLISODAE.DE
G VINDFEINANDIMCTS  DNGENEFDI
CRACDEMO
TTATO DIC ARSNDGGRE AANDIOSSN
IN JUSS,HI IT WAN HAVD TETOAE
AL ALOFN.UD SDEHO TS TT INHI
WHNOOU KW ATAS W THE
-ONREAS -FHE TPEIRST F S
C
ANAMI  SG TOHE
RE Y
DO KNOOUWSOHE R TEAN?
NRSHAT  WWAHE RSON EATO
CRIR THETE FSTER INT?TIONNAALEA
I
>> THIED WE NKNEO T
ON MOVE
TGHRIT ATHEOM MENT.
I K, O SO LLWINS ARWE
HE AND T
REASON FOR WASARITOL SIDY OFWO
ERRKS PUPRIISOLH NGSI AINGAST
A
RUN--N  I4. 186
RGEDUR O -- I PUT IN
ESON T
O- -
>> I'MOR S NRYEETOD
ON MOVE
R
>> Y THAK,NK
Y THA>>NK M VOUERY
OUIN FAL
IPE SAKERS--CT OANA
OFT UN TUFTY.ERIVSI
OUNKHA Y FORLATINV IIO MNGE
ANDITIN INVMEG  TO ART.KETA P
YOU CANE NG EAGE  SWITHOMHEOF T
.
MESODYLR AEAU H  WITYOL
T
PUERBY O SERPEAKSLE SO T ME
K
TABOUT A AEW F
HING TS.
ON TOFHEBL PROSEMBO AHEUT
CU
ENRRT
TON CFLIC ISRHA TT FO
THRE INTERCRCKLOING ESIS.
IA-URUSS..SIONSEL RAT,NUK
ASCHINRAE-TIONREE LAANS D H
SAYTHHA WT ELY DAI --
T WHAMAO
TY BEHEAI MN O
SOT NK THI IERIS VYPF HELUL
ANOR IMPSYNT TTAO ATHYMPUT ABO
O
AE
IAUKRAINNTI DOMESIDYL
MINACS.
BLPUICON OPINI
ANDUT PIN'SA, RUSSIUT PIN'S ALL
THE MAT M CEORATIOOP PUL
H
EN GO MAIS.AL
AN
HOD W TTHAN IN MI TUR
COMP
GINLAIN THE
LULLAL CC
S.L
ALOFHE TSHISE TNGK WOR
ERGETOT.
L ISO'L W TVERA OLLE
SSNL GOA ANDNA G ISRL
IM
RTANPOT
EP TO KE.N MI IND
ISAT IWHS ELHE T TIME TOIN
ACHI
E?
I THULWEK  SHOD TEAKUT P
IN
IS HOR WD TTHAANUS RSIA
UKRAE IIALLSEESNTONY E
OPLE
PE
UKEAS H.RAIIED  DEN S--OS I
NO
ABOONT LYUTO.
NAT
KTHI INT'S  IREMO TO CALIPOTIL
GAONTIUK O
F DE RAINAN
ERAUE
OM
.AI UKRNEWH
HEEN T AN RESSGGIOARTESTD.
RAINUKE WEMOT A N MR OFBE
TO
NA
.
W N ATRALEU C
NTRYOU.
TONA OAS N WOTNHEGE AANDND A
ERTHEY WATNEE GOTIGIN WHITHE TMN
DN VEATTH WASEP UNACCBLTAE
TO
. PUTIN
SO TRA THE STA WDEARNEDRT IHE
L
ND A INSON OGATITIF
IN
ENSUCY
.
SO ITOAN WT K  TALWHT
S
WA
IN SAYG.
THATIN MLDSK C BEEE SN
S  AA
L TENTPOIA.LUTISOON
, RUSSIA ITIB
CTIVJEE
TIF LI OMINGKR UNEAI
UKROUGTHH INERAIN AGREEGSH TO RU
AIRER INTN ETPRATIOOFSK MIN.
LYPEESCIAL- -RS FACTOHA TTOU WLI
VETTLE SEA OVEOW PERR
IAINN
ESTI DOMANC D FEIORGN
CY.POLI
ITBUT  ISPOO LSIMTRTANO T
INTHM
IN
ITF
ISPU DTEF O
NECERIS
YS TORRE
.
ENAVE  HSE STA AAL OFSK MIN
IM
TIEMPLENTAON.
ON TIFHE CTHTIDIONS  AATREOT NE
ES TNTVAAGOKRAINE IT BUT
WO
SENTD ULESGIVELLIAY
SIA RUS
THE SEAMME TUT OCOT HAITLD COU
EU
EVLYAL -
-E  H ANDAVTHET RES
.
SO
, YES MUC, INSKCOH
HE --
ULD COBEECHE O TBJVE,TI A
AY
R PUTINAC TO  WMPLICOSHTHAE H
SEEKS.
AERE THISR BORDE.ON CTEXT
POTEY FOIARECYN IGPOLIND A
THE TIESON ITHS ISCC ATAEPBLE
CUR FOONE ESANRR TO YNTSEIALL DO
WHATMAT YING O  TBRHEANR
UNTR
COYO IT INTSLUEN INFCE
THE METHH ES
ODTHS.I
ULWOD SAYA COUS JT LEUP
O
MORENG THIS.
DETHITE E I TIONVASN,E HHEREAV
U
EY
WHEN U THESA. WA.SS YINGIN
ASSIONVA WT MMIN IENDAN
WLENSZEKYAS SINGAY D'TON
E,TIENALLYOVERS
TADON'T LKT BO AUT IASIN IMM
IHI T INKT S MAKESSEEN BAUECSE
ANYASIO INVN OCC ANDNATUPIOND
TMP BLLENPUY PIT
O  TGE
L OVNTCOROERNE'SKR UAI FOR
ICYNAR P ILATICUR,NK THI
WOI
ULD BEBLRE INCDIICY DIULTO
T
F
IPU HOPE NTI RSEAHIS. T
LL
POINS UBLINOPINC IO
DE
INNSMOTRAT
THG IS.
ETHRO I INYSRU THAT IESHR H SADU
EN ICHNFLUCERAVE OR UKEIN
SINCE 2017
.
FAMI NAROT O--F N IOU YNE
A
DN WOHAECONLS AO EALIICOM D
WH
A.US RSI
INF HIAADENLUCE OVETHR E
A ANMEDIDOW N H NORASDI
S ISOT' MOREY IK LELTHANOT
SINCE01 29BU -- NEEVERT YO
E
V
COSATIERON ENSLEKY.
[IND] RNCEIBLED E ONWOULTGE
ELD TEIN TD THN URANLD WATOU
AL
E.
RNTEAT
I THIT WO TNKHAVED ULHA
UED NTCOINTBUEAR OW N-YRE W--E'
N
LOATG ERY  A VENTFFDIER
POLCAAN L
PEDSCA.LITI
THEEC D ILINEN FPO SUPRTOR ANY
NDFSI RUSA ANI UONVEND OR
50OF THEOP PIOULATN WHO S
AY
EYANLD -OU- MPY TSVER O
NTOF TL HENT COU.RY
THEUM NRSBERE AIGRA CSH HD
L
SOTIUB SSTANE  IALN THSTEA AND
SOUT
THIST IS NOSA TO YCTHE T EXA
ENTAPEGELEF  OPEOPT DOUT B IES
, I MAKEULWODANYRC A,  KOF- AT Y
VE,MENT REUL- WOD SULT IN
A
NTRNGOVEMEOUCH WHI WDOHELD TN
NPUTI'S BNG.DI
NO-  ONENE -ULDWOUP SRTPO
IT.H
HIC WNLD MOUEAEDUSTA SIN
TIOCCY
PUTILU C'SALCUS,IS THIS OT N
PR
EREFRED.
WHEANTSNEKR UAIEEIN AGRGHIS TON
NDINRSDETAG
OF THE M
AGRE
ENEMT.
ENDI'LLSA BYINGPL C AOUEF
O
O.
T
BUHE TTH SPEINLD I WGSOU
S LIKMSEMEE
IT-UITE Q -HA TTUT P LIVINES
WN HISIN OUBOR NE OTTY REALI
R
HE ONLPEYD DENIEHI TS.TH
ISE CHANG INLIC PUB
ON
PII
THATICWHH  I ILLING.TRUSAT
THE NVE TRAARTIEMEDT HASEO TE BO
TED TRNSUCT TH TISHAIS
REFE
ISNCREE  FAL.FISIED
ECLYMAIN BPL PAUSEEON'E DOTT WAN
HR
HI'RTHEYE DINGIR THEANUSSI
PR
.ERENEFCE
SO T J WHOHELE..DOPHE
N D CALLE O
N F THESE
IN --NSIN PUTATAYS  STH
CH
MU
.
TY  ONLPUBLTHIC
API ONION
S
ITOW NBUTA SNDS TUS RSSI
OB
IMOUVISLY CTPA ON
CH THIS
IN PCUBON.PI ONI
IT QUIESAT AGERO DTEANUS
ALIVATE TO REA
TYLI.WERN
KNOON D'TW WE  H
GETSFOM
INIOATN F
I  AS ONITEL PAN WH AUS R
E
EX FRT AEWS DAY. AGO
THW NOWIIE
ESVE AHACCSNO PU TTI S
HY
BE GTINGET IONORMANFTIHELONG A T
A
T YOUT,W, KNOR YOU
PR
SEREFENCE
EL AND W TMECOD ON
STAG A SNDO
OR FTH.
'MAIAGN, I S NOTATINAYG TH'SHE T
UTCASE BHI SOMET TNGO
HI TK
AB.T OUIT
FI POI TY,HESNTT TO JUS
Y
SOGTHMEINHEUTBO TESTE W
RNSPN
RE
HINK T - BWEETENUT PINWE BEN
INND-- AOI GNGIG.
EOE GER OINTHH
S R
FO THEOVID C ACKSTT.
[ILECEISRNIB] AND M THEREAY
E
A RES WTERNTOPOESNSE HI TS.YE
HS,EAN CUIAY MBE G
ALY
THWIT  IT BUIT DEASNOE'T RYLL
EVE ACHISHIATE LT UIMIVEJEOBCT
HWHICMS T SEEO HAV--E  BNGVI
SAYUKRAVE OR E.IN
BUIF YBI GO  TG TORY
TO
EACHI THESETIBJ OECVES.
KTH O
DEUTSI --H IT
NTSUBSTALIF
ISIT NOGE LONR DENBILIIATY ANDF
HE T WTEESRNNSAN SCTIO
, T>>HEREENTHNT G AUARAEE
ACESDON'T  HMPCOLISHIS
E.JEOBCTIV
USE BECALYT NOONHEOE DS  WAN
TEH
THRONTLKRAI U, NEIHINK TE
THENTWAS  WESTOT OGNI RECZE
E
ISY  VERABFUCAREL HOOUT WHE T
D
IARAUKINNTPRML
SOCES
ER, PREFNDEN CNGESHA
N
HIS TNCREFE PREPIESLL'SEN
OBDIVE CTAN D WFEREIFNTS TOAY
E
THE TRE
D ANTHEN HOWES THE WDSRET SPON,
TUGHMIT ACLYALE CHANG PINUT'SCA
N.ULATLCIO
HIGHT M CHAENG FURERES M
OV
.
AFF O.
YHA>> TNKMUEROU VY CH.I'
TOINM GOG OS PESE E ONQU
FR TTOHAHE CT ACH  EOF THE
SPTM
KERSEAND A'LHEN  TWETURNL  TO
A
E OF CHTHAK SPESER AND A I'D
K
EMOH
DDRE ASSHE TNUE QSTIO
ILTO
OTHERUE QEYIOSTN THOU WLD
E
SPECTOIAYLLOM CMENT ON ORF I
EY'D LESE IKTO RNDPO TO
AN
THEHIYTNG
ER S OTHS HAAKPEER
.
SA
OUIF COULDTHEEE KP NTSOM CME
ORT, MEAK TUR M, EEFOUTINES
H
L STWE, 'LVEL ILHA TFOIME R
EC SOND R.OUND
TH
ONESE QUTI IY SIS BACL
WHIP
WOD BE THENO ECO LC INMICH
CAS OFON AON LTERMG-
N
MPAICAGN OF IN?IMATNTIO
JUNIORERA
COUP HEC BAUSEE F GOT AEW
QU
INTIESONS HE THA C
T.
ONE  IN
SARAHE HI WTMORDAN SHE
D
AS
ER YHE WTHLD T COUOU
ABOLA CIMUTENSK ZELYGOM CINYOUR
RUNDESS PREFRURE OMAT NLIIONAST
TFORCO.
O ATWH DYOUEA MN?
D ERE D
OEEOU Y S ANYH SUC
RELI -GHED- KE T YOU
ALKEB
TOU
GAIN AST ZY ELCONGMI
OMFR A THETH WERTHA BE
SU
BYORTEPPD HE T --
FORYA TET
WHRE A
HE T PIES PERORTCKPISFOT
RCILIEC RONIOATNEN TET BWEHE
LD
SED,LAECRE THEPLE' PEOS
RELI
OD REUPCCIEANDONGIS IE KV.
FO
R OY,LEXIT IEA BONESN QUTI IS
WHO D UAINIKRANEO PINPLK
AT
F.
AR
E UIAKRNS
T READYOAKE TAR
D SHOMSULSIA R MOVE
IN
LYLIMITARIND A IIN FALLYFRN OM
ANOXA,IO Q AUESTN THATS TO ASK
WHATTELLX  EININTEENIGT
CRIS
IS W
RUSSHIITN HT MIAIGE B
GIN PSLEUPILN'CT SAN.IONS
JUV
STEM RYBD INEVERY,ODELE PAS
Y
TR EF GO BERIAVWE SO  H
O
ROO A GSECOD NDOU R.ND
TH
ISFLOOE R EA Y.RS
>>ON COFTIONDIS THE
ERLONG-TNRUM SSIAONON CDITI
.
THIS BASEENOI GLO ONGN A
NG
TIMESI NOW, .E NC2014
THIS IST AS EW N,  STAGEA NEW
E
TOFHE REAHEY'NSSO TRE D
N
RE DHE TY'SNGOI IBAS  DON
TOEAK UNEKRAIE LOS
EY M.
LEPEOP WAL TRIO TES INVT IN
UK
LLE RAINWI TCE THINKWITHHE
R
EY WANTVE TO IN INSTOU A CRYNT
E
EST QUA
NT LOW-ISITYENAR W.NO
E
ISTA SINNDGTWN  OITS OFFMO ENT
S AND HADMESO MOLFOS R THE
OMY ECONW.
GTORO
DAN TY'HERE P THETIUTNGE
M
AONEWEL S LEVTHO EY
AREAL
ADREYRIEDLOCK BINADG
OUR
ME OGULFF XICO F,ORCEYO AS U
OWN
CRLIICALAS  IN TAKE--
MA
IS TAKEN AOR OVEY,RW SOK,
W
ERE THISK TALF O ALOTHERNO BCK
CE
TH B MIGHTCKLOAD CE
TND A THA
ULWOD BENO ATHERTA DEVASNGTI
OW T
BLTHO E UKRNIAIAN E.NOCOMY
IS
A HARDUA SIT
EC BALOMICLYNEUT ONG THINOTH
D  GAT'SOOFORIS U TOSE OFFT
LHE TSE
WSE LOSS,E'RE GNGETTI
M
INLATIORNNAMUOM
TIESN.
ANR INFOST,CE THERIME PIS MIN
JOHEN WASOS  TREHE
TH OERAY D.N
NGRPSURISILYOR F US, I
RK
WOGINA  AS JOMARY ALL OF
E.
RAUKIN
Y'RE TSOHEERIN OFFGHINGOM SET
KE
LI2 $
LION MIL- - 2LI MILON
PO
UNPPO DS TSUORT UNEKRAI
.
BEE'THERS RTUPEN SPO INHE T UP
AERE'THS  N FUNEWD FROM.K.,
ANTZERWI L ANDDSWE SEN,EDKAI
TH A MPLOR SAJUPDIOF FY UNNG
RFO UKRDSANNI NEES A
WE.
SOS  THAT'INTEINRESTGAU BEC
SE
SOMEFHE THI TNGS
T HA TT PUSHA
,ODPRUCED REDSAREGDS
HI TSO
TINGLU FSH THEEY A MONA OLLF
D
.EN
IT SILONGTBUETTIOT N GOT ANG L
OF.UP SPORT
HEA BHALYICAL WS
'RRI HEA NIGNG RHT
OW.THEWE
K YOANU.
TER YOUNK VY M
SO SGE
S THA>>NKRFO THEST QUE
IOTH
E LANT WAASS NT IESERTING
QU
TIESON.
-- TGET HAMANAS TNNMAER
CO
ITACNTTS WMIH SSER WATS,IT W
H
HIS  TORPPTERSIROUHRGH DTEC
, BUEEAFLST W DHOID NAGE MOTAN
TO DOPRGAN ONALATIZIO
CA
TYPACI
TOUSBA HNDIS H
TSSUPPOR
S.
RT SUPPO-- HIS
THCAPOLIE TILHAORCE F TIST O D
VEHA
IOOT MIVATLNA A
ANE
EAR AD OCSSIATETHWI THE
RITR O NSTIOATNALIS  FORCEKELI
O
ANPE
ARITOL SIDY.
THNAL AT NIO, THRPCOSEEA SA
RT,. ETC
MY M OO VEEMTONAR WVN
ACDEERE WHI RIBESC THE
NA
DYCS OMIF
Y ELEN ZSKTO
YSICABALL GNE UPIV OOM SE OSHI
L
EARIERO PSEMIS UERND THT NHEIG
NO PIT COO.TILAON
OF SOMEETHST RAR LGE THALIALEST
HAEDCAN  IN I
AN'V IE  -D ON-
EVNND OR OVEIT CIES IN
E
TIREVOLUONC.ARPAS OETHEFHE T
D SE THEALLIES
ERHERE T W
E
RE TOEATSHR TYEL ZENSKHA TT
H
IFEAK M GESOODN  OTHMESO OF E
, OMPRISES B WHEOULDEOVED REM
FFICOMFR OANE DT BELM AOST. TOON
RAFD TE TT,HA SEEE' WVENT
A
E SPDEITIEEAHIS RLRMI PROSES,
E
GAP UN  OISPRTHE OMENGAR REGDI
EH
MA STEINAFORMR UL
STHAT IOT NE
N RAINUKIAW.LA
L, GE AL HSOU VES RAYOUP
N
OMHER OTPRESISE  HLEDE WMAHI
WAINHE TST F
S  MONTH HOFIS
CYESPRIDEN RDINGEG TT DHEIREC
IOGONETIAT, NSFORMPLE E, AM
Y NESTITD ANTHEOM AUTONSOU
STUS
AL
HI TS WASSED EF RERDAN
GUARETIAL PART WA TLYHAS WHY
THATIN,  PUTENWHSA HE WHA TT
LE
ZENSKY N WASNGILOT WLI
FOOWON UP
NO P HISHENONMEPROLL
ASISESOM W NOR  LONGELLINWIG
TODUCTONNY A
NG MEETIWITHS HI C
M.
ALNATIONRCISES ARELL STIVE
TRONRYG KND ANYOU  TOWHAT
TH
EERS I ANIMPE ON CRALINE
CAS
RETUEITHR RNYOU TO  CHEREE,AN T
BEEHAVENIVELEL RATE
LAY RG
TRATMODENSNSIOPPS HISUORT
AN
SD HIOL PARALITIC PTYS I
CA
EPABL OFINIL MOBIZEIG THR
PPTERSDIRO FM
ENFFERT
MUGIONRES CHAI UKRNE.
WASI  OWE-- IN N ERNSTNE UKRAI
HLE COL
UER
LLWECT AESIV WEER MEL TLING
E
THEYEERET GNGTIIT INVIOATNS TO
U
ORPPT
REND A A TEAK PTAR O
T
INDSSEHE KF OALLI R.ES
, IALSOTED  WANEFLY BTORI
AB
ET OUTH FNGINDIST HAXI OLEY
SHH  WAREDITDIEGUS RARHENG TPU
NI OBLICPINDON AINER I CTALY
REEAGTH TATAJ THE MITYOR
F OK
AINIARANSRE VYERALRACT PIC
OU
ABT THEIN MME ASKGREES NTAND
ANJERECT MOFY  --OF MUCH
ITSEM P AROBLOR F
SKY EL ZEN I
T
OTHF EN WHEA RSOYE' HS
LLINUNWIGHEADVEMO AH WIT
TH
ON HTHHE OERWEAND ATW  KNOTH
EL
TKS,
NE AIOTIATNSREY VERTL COSY
LI
PO
LLTICAY.
CAYOU NHEK ATOO TMP EXA OFLE
SP
N ANAID T THEKS OALFTT E
A.
CAN
LOOKLA AT SAA AMAN
D
ET  THAETHEE AGRHNTME WIT
C
ALS WAACTUTE RLYEJECD
T  E
UMFEREREND.
BUE THFACTHA TT
T THESEESYPF O
ININTEENEMT - ISSTRE -
H
ONREE AS TO  NOTYTR
EK TR  OSEM
TEMPLEN OTIATNER GOHEONE  T
S OFTERMHE TSES.GR
MEEENT
T, FINAC ILD WOUCO WELMET THA- -
EXVEEL BIEATS THAI UKRNES I
C
AL
T OUGHTH I NOTIS, ISTT A SSVA
AT
F THEALEDOMRE HLS RING,AT
U
K WACRS NKVENER RA AEDS A
DE
ACY.MO
'SIT NL AOT FUECYEM DOCRAYO IF U
FULL-- YHA TT OU SUPPO
DE
IC DCRMOATELOIAGU AHANG ENDXC
E
OFDEASI,  ITHI TNKLD B WOU
EET
GR IF WETED ET DECETH
FIBENETS AND OER MTZE F TH--
RI OFHE T M
EE AINSKGRSMENT
IN
LI PUBC OSITELEN VIUTON B
UN
ELRTUNFOATTHISY  IS N
OT
PPGIN
ONNE UKRAIIS TELEV
BEOPUSCAE PE IN FAR OF THE
MI
K AGREENTSELD WOU B
ATMEITR
TOAIRS.
U.ANTHK YO
>>NKHAOU Y.
TNAETYAXT.S  INE
>>, IURCOSE DAVE'TON HN A
IONOPINLUSTO  TILMY
TERAD
ONSIPOTI I BUTAN CNAK SPE O
LFBEA
LAVES-- TO  WHOE  LIVE.THER
I
OU WAYLD SHA TTHT FOESEHT IG
S
O DAN MORE D M
EOR RLIZEEA
AD
STATIAPON FOR.EA RLITY
THEY AIE TDSS TO RUNIA
TI
CI
NSZEHIP.
EYTHRE ATORY TING OBIN FDS JINS
SSRUIA OLOCATHN E LT ANAR MKED
TH
-- [ERNIDIINSCNDE]BL AVE EN
IN THY SUT APEAKBO
AE
AT A CEI FORGNRYOUNT.
AYSTJU S UN
NTRNO RE TOKR UNE.AI
I
INKTH
WI THIS TILLNU
TH FD URE UTANI AMESOMEM TI
S E
LYGIONREALM  FRO S M--AYBEEOMDO
TN'NO KW.
TBUIN MSK, EEGRMENTRFO ME IT'S
O
MOR ARENDE
LESS USE.
RNEKR UAI
--EVERANSI LEAGM FRO
K
REENTS ANTHEND T ITIEGRAON
S
ANBLSS ULESAFORE AI UKRANSNI
LS
TH
YAJ MORITAS H RHUSEN --ND
TEORITYES DOOYTRED S B IIEELVERH
THE  IATN XTNE
FEW,EA YRSHE T
MIWILLLKTAS E BESS L
LESS
IMPNTOR INNI UKRAN AND
SSCSLIN POTI.
ANH
T--. YHANKOU
>>OUHA TNK YCHER VY MUEGARDI
THECEOR --US JNTA T MOME
I SWA L TTEISNING COLO LEUEAGS
N
I D AM L
WHN IE ERCA DRATEONEMST
?
OK.
ARSHEEE SCR
SO
RRY.
TI WIELLOU YHA TI SET NTN
T  I S--ENA LKIN.
IT AS  IALSOLEG RIONAAKDO BRE
SOAY M SEEIFFEHE T D,
S
U MAT BUYOSEY E BAS,ALICLY EVE
IN THEANDAS ET  SER, OUTHTHAE'S
F
GERALAI UKRNIANND TRE,H WITNE
ALS
MESOEDDY ABOSKE MBO AS ACCUTES
LI S.
I DLLWI SEN
IT.
RDREGAGINESTT AITUD F,ORWE
R OWD HAOUN,OL PLSND T AER
H
S, TPOLLREY HEWE M.ONENTIED
A YAD
TEABE RDY
GHO FIT.
POHEANOTR RTIOL WILU S
E
OTMY BARY RHENS MEAGMEAN, IN
MONR
--HO STOAYT?G -  -BEIN
A
DONO TOFHE BLOOD
OR F E
ANUNWODED
SOD  ON.
SOMEEEO PPL WOOSEL ILCH
ARATE
STI DO OGYF T C'N'
MYEGY TR SATLLWI BE T
T
W20%,AL IHICHS SO
RSUNDE.ABTANDLE
ITHISTALENDAB.S
T LEME EBORALATEN  O
IOGOTINEATNSTH WITH RYMILIE TA
WT
A
OFME, LLLET AY SM I AEA R
U
YONO KW, SIKTRE THE  BY
HEATIO NLINA
ANDSTS,
HAT
DOEAN OU Y MBYNALIAT NIOSSTN IAC
TADEMER
LIIO NATNAST,RIENTE CR-
GHRO
POENKOSH
ARTY P?
R FURTHE
RI
RIFAR
DITNOT OEMAND YKEOU U
D
GOATWH IS GINN, OEC B YOUAU
LYY MASIMP SAY WNI
COUN
EREY TRTHILL BE OF L AOT
ERENDIFFLOGIIDT EOM TH FESRO
EFT
LERIGHTH TO E
TFROMHE LEFT TO R.IGHT
LEPEAND OPERDI OF FFICETENT HN
AL
EXTHE PLEAM OF AISPNND A
IACOLOMB
.
TIS PAR OFA OL COMBI BCUOCPIED
Y
OTHE C?NTOURIES
WOUSSRUIAE TO LLDIKNT
RE
IT AVILA S CI CT.
FLONIC
TH AE ERISTYES NECSI TOK, TAL
IT BUIFUP OT ISCC
BYIEDA
IGFOREN P J WOWERHOSTUST AL
TH,PE PUPTSOUOW H C
LD WNEE
ATGOTIE?
DTHATMES NOOET WE THAANT
E.CA M
AAGS HAVEI D, SAI I
THN E
MI
KNS AGREEERNTME, TH
ISEO
NTMEIONUT ABOE' P AEOP'S
REPU MICBL, NOTTIENON ALL A
WHENE TAE  WARABOUINLKG
TRTAI
CEN DTSTRISIC, ITEANS M
LOCA
UNITCOL MM
ASSO BLYICAL, IMET F, ASO
,
BEAGE CAUSI  TWIREE THOAN TYA -
B
ICH
,HANG CES
I.EI
T--HECC ORTIEUPD PAEWHS O AR
EAKINGANKR UAINI SLLTI.
TELYFIDENIISOLEE FL  IATN
ISTHN.
EG RIO
BASSO THEALICLYA
IRES
SSIBPOTO MITILY RWARE OVFO
H
ONUSDISCSIND AR N  EVEFO
THII
REO ON TIN-  -TOOY ENJ
LICENTDERATIONZA,AS BUT BALLYICE
INGANGO SELF-RNMEVENT,
SE
ERLFNMT ASEN A C,MUOMNITY
CAT THE LMUOMNITYELEV.
SO CAG, AIN,ESPROMOMIS
LEPOSSIB OBU, T INREERRD TO
THEM,NEED WE LFILO  TFU
SOE
RICUTYSONS REA
KY WLEZENSTL ILNOE AB BLE T
OLKF
TAOLITUTBO PONCEALIC C
'HE TRES NOECUR SIT
TH IERE
NCA HHINGE T ESN PRENHETO T
E
.OPLE
Y,FINA AED FBOUTRES.OUOM HSE
UG
USA
TIE
D
NOT  TIVRVE INSHIIT CAPACY
-
UNCOTRY.
RTUNFOWEATUNELY  SID D NOTVIURVN
HI TSAC CAP
T NOHA STOAY TAITT  IS
CRACDEMO
ITESSIIMS PR I
IT IBRIDA S HYE.
EG RIM
CANWEIT AAL CL D REYB HRI
,
ALTOBUT  CLORAU IT TH
IA?
COMEN. O
WED AN DEMDEGNRETHE SI AN ATIOOF
N
ISBUT THOT IS ANY,R STHEOR B
THXAS AN I ELEMPF OIV C
IC
TIPE, HOSMW  NLE AOPRE
OT
LEND A HOW TREY HEARE Y ADTO
U
SDET MANDEF AND DACADENEM
C
EEFRCAMSDO, BECAE USBASI
T
SWAGA AIN ION,RUNTSI
RVENINTEF THONTI OETRYIN MISF
O
IONUCEDAT IN TSSROHE PCE
N
EVKI.
MAYOU Y SURN EE OYOS' TV'YTODAHO
W ITD APPE HNE
D THANE
EATIVESS NOTNL OYROM F KIEV.
KTHAN. YOU
>>T NEXISKS O
>>HA TNKOU Y
.
T LEME ME AKONE CN MEOMNT O
MIG.K NSTHIN
'D'
GY IRASTTEINE.UKN RANGS
'DOI N'KTHT INBE SO  IE CAUSITS
POASHEANT  HET SOM
TO
GAIN DLLTIOMESCA
--UPSIVEAS S SRT FPOOR
D
OFED ARMAR MY TIONACIN AGA
T
RAUKISIN NAR POTOPULATRO FM WH
IWE SEETHN EAN RUSSIOS PT PITIT
LYIL WL ONOM BECT--E  POSIT P
--OROST PUHARPTIS TE HA
DOBE
G D GOANINTWN TDOHA LINE O
F
THINAY, NGTO SREHE TRE A
ONSANCTI RONS  THESIUSAN
AROLIGS CHNOTE  ABLS ATOCCES
PRTHEIR  AEROPTIESRT SNDO FO
H.
EYTHOAY M ALS BSPINEG TO
E
REATTH THEAY M BE EFSIROON O
ORT,SUPPO YO S THAFIU NDHE
T
OMES DCTITEONXT.
THATS AT IWHLD I WTH O SAYN E
SSNU
LE ANG.
DOTHE OLICMEST PGLS ITICANE.
LLI WILY QUI CNTOMMEN  O
TC
DIE SIONUS W AVE HHAAD
BO
MPCOS,ROMP IIOMENTLEAT
NO
RAUKIKINE SK ZELOFEN
SEMPROCOMI AND WEDRE PVENT
.
THE ERTFOUNAT DS AMYNIC I
THREREMO AGGRUIVSSELY
IASS
--PUSN
AGAITAI UKR,NEND AL HE T GOA
S
CONTOFL  THE C, THNTOURYE VOET
COUOF 'RYNT'REIGSOS VE
DE-MAKSICIONG,IN TS LI LHEES
ENT,ESPRIDOR FHA TTR,AT MTE
R
ISON A, WAYTA TO  TBOLK AUTHEI.
GONDNSATIO A CN DEONCE O
S
NDFUTAAMENLRO C AING SSOF
DLREECL
ATUSSTWO THAT DULE  GIV
MF
GIESE THREVEONTOVER O
INUKRANIAOM DD TIESC AN
RN
CY, POITS  IVERYNL UELIKY.
THWIUS RSIA, THE LSGGRE A
E
IT WE, TLDOU BE MHEOR L
ELIH
LD WEYOU MEAKOMISOM CPR
N
EMRAARNGKIOMOR SE NDIN OF RMALFO
TL ALOFHESENG THIHES, T
IFSPECIC DINTMITH OF E
EMAGRE TENHIWO THENKY D BEULK
E
SSIK LI Y, SELO STULD WOJU
S
THCAND W AE UECONTN IN
TSC
DI
SIONUS.
>>NK YMU VEROUY
AVWE HE A SETTIF  OQUESCH
SW
ILATTH I WLUP GRO
N  ITHE
GLLFOOWINAY W
.
ONE  TONHE WT,ES ONEN O THI
SSU,
IST IS WOFHANG RRI DVI
OTHED ANANON HONR E
RAINUKNSIA -- RAINE THUK
POLI
ESTACATIL ENT ISBLHM
ISACTI
RE
SOWOT  WHAI S DOULD  I
TO
ROFFEFITH IN E IN10NAL  M
E
HAVEAC EHAK SPE TP ER UTOWO
NUPO RS TOESNDAN TO UY YO
WO
DULE  LIKTBUEF HOPCALY WULE
N
KEEURGE WE EALL T TH
ONQUESY
NADICONG YEMAR RKS
OU
GH MNT TWAO
THEST QUEHEN IOON T FES WT IS
O
RTMAINND ABOT  IIS AO HUTOW D
U YOSEASSSHE TF EV LEL O
F
STWEERN C INTOURIESTHN IS
CRIS
E QUTH ON TIESONN DRSSRUIA
S
RO FM HOREAC, WH WOUH ICIS
RU IN EA RCTETH SAME U WAY
IFT
T E  WERNOO NOVERAT B
VR
JOINUKRAE EG ININTHU? E
XTTH IWHO
THD
RSPPORSUTEG EACT RIN
DIENTERTHAY W TO S CISRISIFF
HETHAN TYO  DID TISE THCRISHA TL
EDAY OUTT  LASITRISPNG W
H
RUSSNOP TROEM MOVTSENTE IN
OFTONGSI IT RUS PH FOAT GREER
U
FOR ORPPT TONA MEMP.
RSBI
THRE I TENHEESTIA S QUM
FO
COELWELLBO AUTOW T H
UKCUN INIASERITY SARCEERVIS E
AD CSIDRESNGTEEROUNTIN
EE
THRESED S ATPOSIAN RBYUS
ESCA
ONLATI.
EVE THPRST QIOUSUEWAION SM FRO
.A
FRO--MIA NATAL.
LWE WIL T GO INHE W ORDER
E
STARANDD UE I REQE PSTEOPL
TAKERE NO MOO HA TN TW
NUS
L R FOFINA
MARERKS.
SO,
WE WRPRIE ERSUTH TD SEWI
HE
UN WES TINHE
HEYENWH TER WG ETE MEIN
E
A ITUP WH OSNGSTRO PN.ITIO
THBE ME 30EMFRS O JAT NO,
E
CTIPOSIONOFCARITIL  'USSI
S
TIONACS.
ATTHLD C RNGE HAOFSIAUS
IN
ESED MDEOVN I WITHOME
ONINVAL
K WE
ENAV HE SEISO  SFAR
ING.RETESTIN
ANTHMAD NY OAT IERNITIESIV.
I PEULWOD HO TD Y HEWOUL
UNEINRME THG,NI UFYINENTOH CER
TIONPOSIE WEN  OTHST, BUT
POLA
EAT , NDGRN,ITBRAI
MA.CRON
THMAARERE E S HINY TNGGGOIN
.
NTPAAPREON EVELYRY WIN TE HE
T
D IS KINOFNE AWAKESTO TD HI
ITNEA
HELR
D ANHTAT MTHIG SRODU PCE
OM
DINITYND ANTIFFE DRELA P
NS
BUSOUK FAR, INRAIANS ARE
D PLEASEHA STOEE T NWET  ARE
OT
ROWNTH THEND UERUS B.
>> TER
FIRIC.
THU.
K ANYO
>>LYRI BEF Q T, ONHEIOUESTN O
IM
INHEIES,TR T
USBNT E
CLITTLETYDIBIRELIINN UK IRA
E.
SETHE ERRICUTY SCEVIS  I
A
VE A CRYLOSE OOCSSIATEMRF .
ZENSLEKY, WHO H
BASEEN
EDPLIMICATMBN  IA NU OERFSC
DAANLS APT CNDORRUDAN IOSCAN
S
AS W
NO  HITASCALLIPOTI- IT -AS H N
E
IN FROENNDCETICAPOM LI
LTERF
IN.
ENERCE
IT IEDVIS EW AS LLY SIBACA
AVE
LEITIC PR OFOLALTR CONOL
T
NSZELEKYSE UER OS INRDETTA TO RG
ND
RE S
Y EN VBEERCRRIOUSES ICISITMS
O
KYZELEN''SIN ADMN TRATISIO
FOI
REINGSTHE TF ALLS C O
E
THN WT
O
REEC TRMHE SRVITURY SE
ETHER B HASEFN EENO RM OROFHE T
TYSECURI AER SVICE UEMTTPTED
E
THNTRE PSIDE
ERA NUMBF OLOTS PT HA THAN
E
EDVEREALY BELEN ZOME Y,SK S
OFF
THCTUALLY,T JUSSE RAIOT A L
EREMSE VBLREY CDIE, ANDEY DNO
UNELUNFORTATEST Y, IDOM S NOTEE
C
ITRV
SEES AICRERE PREPA
SECKSLY OUTA THELEBL POSSIEI
SU
ERSIBVONFF ETHTS BORY
E
RUENIASSN AG
AVALI SO HINTOE  REMYOD U TTHA
NSE THZELEIS AKYDMINION TRWA
S
SEYSL DAGAMEDE
Y  BTH
TIONVERELASROM  FGLLBIIN-
-
GLLBIINTAB -- OUHEREAILU
TO
STU CAPREHEOFOME  T
RUPRSSTSAI
TROT
M  FAVELROKMINS TO AURKE TY,
D
E EY WTHER TPPOSSUED
O PT
CATHED BURY EANKRAI UNI
D
RMINFOIOATN,IT SO EAAS W REVS
E
THOM SE OFHI TELES AKAG M
HAOMOM CE FR WLEHIITN ZEKYNS'
S
CIRC
S.
Y,FINALLO NO I D TO WAT NT
A
GBIOINT P O OFT, W IT HAI
-- I I W BT,UTT ANTOW  STHE
MOACY SSCORE FAIOR UNE
HEOE
OUAS Y S CEEE,  YOUTH
ACMODECRR
W BER LONT PFOUROIS IN
E
FTRIODPE ARA THEER O
NG
LUREVOON.TI
STAURATEDGN DGINHE TRE POUVIS
PRENESIDCY U AND AERND THE
DE
COCH WHITH -- T GAE NNET
PITCH -TH- E PNCY SIREDE
FH
AT ANDT I REAEV NERACHEY LLRE
TH OATF A DELLFUY
T
E.AT
ANTHK Y
OU.
>> OK.
ANTH
TUILWE WL RNANTA TO TIA.
REE ONMON UEST QIO ACTDIREED
YO
U FROML, MIKAEHO WSKS A
WH
U HER ETYOAGULD COIME AIN
FE
RALDEEL MOD,ON CNAITUTSTIO
L,
FOR ATINE RATHOULD CAK M
E
DONBIL WNGLIO  THIAYST WIT
N
RAUKINE,IN AS AIHE T UKR
DE
FENI
TIRAON?
>> T.NKHA YOU
LIEVI BEESPECHA TT STIAATUS
RFOSKUG LANHEIN --  T PDERIO
THEEBETWN ROE EUMA
RET TIONLU A
OTHEANR.
-- INI KEV PUTBO THEEROW AND
DONE
K.
N I CA--AGIMINE AN I C
IMAG
ERE E INWHCAL E THLOLEPE
IN
D ANDETONSKSKUG LAN A
UKDE WOINULON CTROL
NBGRND A AEETHIT WH
MMREI COYOEND UD  REAMYICLERT,
OFHADE SS ED F WALISERM,
HS
THS DEA  IWADPLAIEXNEN I
.DETAL
>>HA TER YOUNK VY M
ALS EXI.
MAMUTEE YBUN
.
>> Y
H.EA
I LOWI FAMOLHENG DISNSSO
UCHTHWI S PE.
ASLEUR
DEHESO T IA OFER FEDNATALIZIO
HA
UK
NSRAIN.
EMAYBER A VEY CL PTER
AEDE PEONERHAFTER A TT,
FEER
REIZENTRECALR ION ATPE
TT
IS
-- DIZENTRECALION.AT
ATTH.S  ITRUE
SPEOPLE TPOUPRTEDNOT HABUT
T
FEDE.ZALITION
SODI REGAR -NG-RYOR
.
AM SI
RYOR.I
T  LOSMYD  MINKITHINNGBO AUT
THE P.OLLS
OWSOOK,  NINGA, RERDMEEG FRDO
HOR
DON
ETHOR W
GREEN,EE THR COLS, GENRE,
YE
IOWLL ANDEL BIEVE S BLUE,
O
AFTEREE, OU Y SYU YOMA REF
F
RTE THA
IN 25,00 UKRASNEAI WZEOG RECNI
S
AREE, NT COURYREWEBUT  A
T.
HEBY T, WAYNK T IHIGR P THEROESS
UKMAHAINE S DEER AFTURO E
MI
EDASSESSAT ACCURYEL BYNO
ANEUROPECTNT IELLE
LSUA AT
EXO RTPES WH GE ARALSO
NGO
EITCRICIZ PEMS,RO ANDVE
A
OF PLOA T SBLROEMU KNS  AYO
B
WE AILSTL REREE, F WE
MA
OPLEE THPE MATOE DSDOF
Y, RNAFILLNG TAREGDIHE QN,STIO
H
THITAT WH N SSE RUIAONREAC
HETO TA IDE OEF THSSRO PCE
ON
JOEETHING E ? YOU
T LED REMMEIN Y WHAOUTAP H
INED3 PE01ERANKRAI UNI
Y
ONTEDWA T HAVEE- A FREADTRE
ZONE
EEA FRONRA-TDE Z WWEE  HAD
HIT
RUS
EH
ETH AN WTED  Z-TEERADE
ATWHAS W'UT PINACTIS RE
.NO
CAYOU HEINN JO TTO CUSMS U.NION
OVNYSO A MTEMENINUK BY RA
O
MEBECOENND IEPFA IDENTS CED BY
'PUTIN'ALS BRUTKS A
UNUNFORTELY.AT
IT IS S ABOUTTIE IROMRA
VIINS  HIS W MIND,ECH WHIEREW
NE
EACOLLESGU.
,FOURUTIN P- FO -RIN, PUT
INIAUKRACRACDEN MO THRISY  A
H
KANA
OU Y.
A>>ASHEND T LNUO T TWMI
E
FORNA OXA.
>> WQUTHITH E LEONESTI AASXI W
AN IINSWERG,NDRE AM MIED OF
20IGTHE , ORSINF THTCURRE EN3
GABENO
E GONETIATRAFRA EE-T
DE
AGRE
SWE FAWIRST THEARRA TDE W I
N
THE FALL13 OF 20
ND A THE
NCNSCOEQUE AESFTERHAT, T
OA
HE QESIS TN TOSTUEIO ME,
H
K INIT IS ETH CTHATSIRIS
ME
TNHAKRUT ABO U.AINE
WIREI AGE
HITH TS.
THATAI RQUTHSES E WHONESTI, AT
ULSFSATIYIN PUT?
IO OWHATPT H DO NSWENGE MOAVVI
RWARFOD?
FOAND UNY UNATRTEL NEY ATHRE
OT
EAGR
E THERPOE TWARO IEIBILSSIA
DND ANE O T
RIBLERE.
THLETEE RRIBEOULD W B TNT HAPUTI
SDECIDE T AINO VADEND AHOMCCPLIS
ALHIS GOTAF  OREESISBLHING H
IS
SPHEINFL OUEORE NCBY F
ED ANTH, TH BADLEE SS TER
S
TINU C AONOF WIOATN  SEET HAWE
W, ANOANDEBN B  FLOW,
OR FO
'N'NG ALO,H WITN  AASSINGF
HEN,N
NAGAIG.SS AMAIN
RETHEY AITAS JU T
RYMILITAGRAIN TINHE AND T
Y
ANNOT PLNG TNIOK, ATTACDO S
TNONK THIN NVAS IIO
IS
ETPRED
MINEERD.
D ANETH Q ISTUEION,ON D'
K
GOI TT,RY SOR
.
OT-- G IT, SRYOR.
>> A QUEIOSTNF WH O
HEETRZE
NSLEKYEACT RFERE DEDIFO
T
RISIISTH C THETHS AN L OAST
NG?SPRI
ANY ?
KETARS
OTHEISRWE, WDWHOE. SULUPRAP
.
TE MAYBATT POHIS INDHOWE SUL
P.U
>> M THI INKAY B WHEREE I
OS
JUT DD T AHAWE THESI CRI
SASIFEHOWOM DECRENTFE B
E
VEL LEOFA YS HTERIYISRAED B
RTIPUN ISGHLLEAY HIE AND W
DON'TW  KNOMAATWH HE Y DOR O
OUWHAT WN HLDAPPE NTEXAUSE BEC
-- WE T N'D'TANDDEUNRSHAT W
PUTIN WAN TTSO
FRIDASE ACHEOM T FEATT TH HIL WL
AI USTOPKROC DNIANEM.RACY
>> HE WI WLLRAE TOAV WITP U
ANKTHO  YOU TOUCH OEAF
R
EA FORRS AT DI
UN
ANDE INTEVI T YOUIFVIO EW,
YOU'REER INTHETEESD, T.EB WSITE
JUI LA CSTIRCUD TETHE
INN
WSECA YOUELDOU LIK MORE,
INFEREG INREESNCME OO  TSO
O
THCYLI ANDEM MOSTHER O
INGSWRITCHOLUR O SSARAVE H
ENTEPRES THEOVD ER ABOEA YRSUT
THS.
OP TIC
THAGYOANK U ONARTOAIN  P
SGTSHIN
EUSIA,WARG GEOE
TYERUNIVSI ANDON EVERYWHOE AT
ODNDEDTE THI FORAY TS EVENT
K  LWEOOTOARFORWD IN SEE
T
ENHER OT